good evening everyone welcome to the
housing works bookstore cafe I have the
great pleasure of introducing this
evening this event this evening my name
is Molly Michael I am the director of
marketing here and I'm happy to welcome
c-span and book TV back to the space to
cover this really fabulous event before
I tell you about our participants this
evening I just want to give you a very
brief overview about housing works and
the bookstore for those of you who don't
know much about the space or about
housing works we are a non-profit
bookstore all of our stock is donated
will run almost entirely by volunteers
and all of our proceeds go toward
Housing Works Inc which is the largest
minority controlled aids service
organization in the entire country and
we serve without tens of thousands of
clients annually we provide housing and
advocacy at the state and city and
federal levels and it's it's even more
important to provide these kinds of
services in New York City in particular
in this country because while in New
York City we make up three percent of
the the United States population we are
home to sixteen percent of this
country's AIDS cases so here here in New
York we really are ground zero for the
for the epidemic nationwide so thank you
so much for coming out this evening and
supporting such a such a great cause and
also we if you are ever interested in
visiting our website all of our events
are posted you can make a donation to
Housing Works Inc its housing works or
jen i incorrect org and i encourage you
all to to go there and now i have the
the great pleasure of kicking off this
author to author event with dr. pw
singer roger rosenblatt and moderated by
chris hedges and so forgive me for for
this canned introduction but i want to
make sure that that i introduced these
guys properly and give them the credit
that they deserve dr. singer is the
national security fellow in the Foreign
Policy Studies program at the Brookings
Institution and director of the
Brookings project on US policy toward
the Islamic world he's written for the
Boston Globe the LA Times New York Times
Washington Post Foreign Affairs current
history Survival International
security and world policy journal he's
provided commentary on military affairs
for media outlets including ABC
al-jazeera BBC CBS CNN Fox and NBC and
this event this evening is to discuss
his new book published by pantheon this
month children at war and also
participating this evening is roger
rosenblatt he's a journalist and author
playwright and teacher his essays for
the NewsHour have won a Peabody and an
Emmy Award his essays for Time magazine
of Warren 12 george polk awards his
journalism career began in nineteen
seventy five is a literary editor of the
New Republic he's been a columnist and
an editor-at-large for Life magazine
editor of US News and World Report a
columnist and editorial board member of
the Washington Post and editor-at-large
of Time Inc his work has appeared in the
new york times magazine Vanity Fair the
New Republic Esquire and I'm sure many
many many more places his book children
of war an account of young people
growing up on modern battlegrounds from
Northern Ireland the Middle East and
Cambodia won the 1983 robert f kennedy
book prize and was a national book
critics circle finalist and finally our
moderator this evening Christopher
hedges is a reporter for The New York
Times was a war correspondent for nearly
two decades in Central America Africa
the Middle East and the Balkans he is
the author of war is a force that gives
us meaning which was the National a
national book critics circle awards
finalist and his new book losing Moses
on the freeway America's broken covenant
with the Ten Commandments will be
published in june so please check that
out when it comes out and now I have the
great pleasure again of welcoming these
three to the table thank you
lunchy start I wanted to begin by
thanking all of you for coming out this
evening and I thought it best to start
off what's a chilly evening outside with
the chilling quote this is from a young
boy in West Africa I was attending
primary school the rebels came and
attacked us they killed my mother and
father in front of my eyes they took me
with them they trained us to fight the
first time I killed someone I got so
sick I thought it was going to die but I
got better my fighting name was blood
never dry as our moderator mentioned my
researches on changes in warfare and
particularly the rise of new forces in
warfare and how it affects national
security and children at war looks at
one of the darker sides of this the rise
of child soldier groups is nobel peace
prize winner Archbishop Desmond Tutu
said quote it is immoral that adults
should want children to fight their Wars
for them there is simply no excuse no
acceptable argument for arming children
the problem is while there's no moral
excuse this practice is out there and
it's growing every single day and so
what the book seeks to do is take the
first comprehensive look at it why is it
happening how is it happening what are
the implications of it and with that
what can we do about it and in the book
I tried to tap into expertise everything
from military history to neuropsychology
the interviews I did for it ranged from
child soldiers to mercenaries who'd been
hired to fight them and my hope and
writing it was really three things the
first is once you learn of this issue
and the fact that it's out there but so
few people are aware of it you feel
compelled to tell these stories and get
the message out that these children are
not only victims they're also heroes at
the same time the second thing is that i
wanted to tell it in a way that was not
only interesting and brought the tragedy
to the front but also added to
understanding with the idea that
our responses so far have not been
effective and part of that is because we
haven't dealt with the real underlying
causes of what's going on and hopefully
this will help answer that and then
finally I wanted to offer new lens to
look at this issue not just the pure
moral tragedy of it but point out that
there are some real-world implications
for it in real world implications even
for us in the West who don't know about
this for example the fact that our
soldiers are out there dealing with it
every single day and with that we see
that there's not just a moral obligation
to act but a strategic mandate to act as
well and today Security's the new coin
of the realm and hopefully that will
force our hands a little bit so um what
I'd like to do in sort of the brief
remarks today is talk about where this
has come from what's happening out there
what are the causes of it and then later
on we can talk about what can we do but
I think it's important first to start
off with the history of this the rule
once held in warfare that children had
no place in it neither as victims Norris
participants now the rule is that war is
not complete without them to put it
another way when you look at the last
4,000 years of warfare when children
appear in it it's mainly as footnotes in
small isolated instances for example and
navy ships of Admiral Nelson you had the
powder monkeys which were young boys who
ran ammunition back and forth in our
Civil War there was one battle the
battle a new market in 1864 where the
Confederacy used a unit of 247 VMI
cadets but these were exceptions to what
the rule used to be and we typically
didn't see children present at all we
didn't see them as targets we didn't see
them serving in combat enrolls and no
one rushed out to copy the examples
today it's a far different thing on the
victim side in the last decade more than
2 million children have been killed in
warfare on the participant side there's
more than 300,000 child soldiers out
there there's another half million
children who are serving in armed forces
that are
at war right now another way to look at
these numbers is if you take the entire
collection of the world's Armed Forces
everything from militaries to insurgent
groups to terrorist groups forty percent
of them use children twenty percent of
them use children under the age of 12
another way to look at the numbers is
that children fight and almost
seventy-five percent of the world's wars
they fought on every single continent
but Antarctica so they're out there in
their present and it's important to note
that sometimes people try and quibble
with the age point of 18 as being the
childhood point and there's a couple
things to say about that the first is 18
is not just some Western construct it's
actually international law the most
widely signed international law 190
countries have signed that law but it's
also the age point at which countries
all around the world award different
rights and privileges everything from
health care to education devoting but
even when you look at history when you
look at military history this age point
was something different for example of
when someone joined warfare the Zulu
tribe in Africa wasn't until you're
between the ages of 18 to 20 that you
were allowed to serve as a warrior and
the ancient Greek armies in the Spartan
army there were young boys between the
ages of 14 and up but they only serve as
herders of the cattle that followed them
they didn't serve as combatants in
northern Uganda where there's a
particular child soldier problem right
now during the tribal period you weren't
allowed to become a warrior until you
were married because it was such an
honor and a privilege today that's been
flipped on its head and this is the
final thing to notice that we're not
talking about 17 and a half year olds
we're talking about those at the age of
childhood that any sane person would
describe it the average age is 12 and a
half that's from two separate surveys
the youngest ever child soldier was a
five-year-old in Uganda the youngest
ever child terrorist was a nine-year-old
in Colombia and so what this means is
that now as a consequence of our
military deployment after nine eleven
our forces have come into contact with
child soldiers everywhere they've
deployed well it's not been discussed in
the media that much we've also fought
child soldiers every single place that
we've deployed the very first US combat
casualty in the war on terrorism was the
Green Beret sergeant who was killed by a
14 year old sniper just a couple months
ago our forces in Afghanistan picked up
a 12 year old who taken part of an
ambush of US forces there in Iraq the
practice has grown before the war Saddam
Hussein set up this force called the osh
ball Saddam it was a paramilitary unit
of boys between the ages of 10 to 15 and
it served as a feeder organization into
the saddam fedayeen which was this
paramilitary unit that was run by his
son Uday and a lot of people remember
the Fedayeen because these were the guys
that actually fought back during the
invasion as opposed to the Iraqi army
that mostly ran child soldiers fought US
forces in at least three different
cities during the invasion but it's
after the invasion during the insurgency
that it's taken off a good indicator of
this a dark indicator of this was the
fact that the very same week that
President Bush made his mission
accomplished speech on the aircraft
carrier an Iraqi twelve-year-old in the
city of Mosul fired on US forces with an
ak-47 and since then it's taken off all
three broad insurgent groups used child
soldiers the posted on Baathists the
radical Shia groups and some of the
pictures that we're seeing here are from
multi dar sauders mufti army that fought
in a pitched battle ended off and
actually the spokesperson of that army
didn't deny they had child soldiers and
they were as young as 12 actually
extolled it and said this was an
evidence of the fact that we are a
popular army that both the old men and
the young boys are coming out to fight
for us and then finally the Sunni
triangle and the fighting there we've
seen it in November the US Marines went
back into Fallujah and they talked about
the challenges of having to fight quote
children armed with assault rifles so
this is an issue that's very real and
it's one that we're having to deal with
and where I'll end in the discussion is
why is this come about why is this
happened right now and really there's
three things that have come together
here there's three causal factors the
first is we're living through the most
prosperous period in human history but
we're also leaving people behind and in
particular we're leaving a cohort of
children behind and you could put this
in terms of there's now a lost
generation and so all the ills of the
world are falling hardest on children
there's more than 250 million children
who are homeless out there there's
another 25 million children who are
refugees are internally displaced a
special at risk group that these warlord
groups target or orphans and that cohort
is larger both because of warfare but
also because of disease by the year 2010
43 million children will have lost
either both or one of their parents to
AIDS so what that means is it's a larger
pool of potential combatants but it's
the second force that what is activated
this this wouldn't have mattered a
couple of generations ago but there's
been changes in warfare and particular
changes in the technology of warfare the
military looks at what are described as
light weapons the assault rifles the
RPGs they described them as man portable
weapons and these are the main things
that are really used in warfare today
not the big-ticket budget items that we
talked about in Congress but actually
these are the ones that most people use
and cause over ninety percent of the
casualties what's happened now is that
they're not just man-portable their
child portable they're lighter because
of the incorporation of plastics they're
simpler and easier to learn how to use
the ak-47 has nine moving parts and
ten-year-olds will tell you how they
learned how to use it in under 30
minutes they're proliferating there's
more than 550 million small arms out
there in the globe enough for one for
every 12 persons which means that
they're cheap you can buy an ak-47 for
the price of a goat in Kenya and then
finally they're far more lethal that
ten-year-old has the same firepower as a
civil war wretched
and so that means that children can be
effective combatants they may not be as
good as professional soldiers at the
start but they certainly can be enough
to cause disruption in civil society
particularly when targeting unarmed
civilians and over time they can become
quite good one of the interviews I did
was with a former US Green Beret who was
now working in Africa in a private
capacity and he had been training a unit
of child soldiers and he described the
child soldiers he was working with as
the best soldiers he'd worked with in
his 18 years of experience in Africa not
the best child soldiers but the best
overall and then finally it's the
context of war that matters warfare
itself is changing we have this image of
war as men in uniform fighting for the
political cause of their nation state
and it's not like that it's men it's
women and it's children the groups that
they fight in or everything from state
armies and that's increasingly rare to
warlord groups to insurgent groups to
terrorist groups and the causes are
rarely political now their religious
socio-economic personal profit sometime
the reasons don't even make sense and
children in these groups are even beaten
if they ask what is the cause he saw
that for example among kids in Sri Lanka
and it's this context of failed States
and conflict entrepreneurs who profit
from the existence of warfare that's
driving this in the postmodern morphing
of warrior and civilian and the best
case example of this is the story of
Charles Taylor Charles Taylor was an
escaped convict from Plymouth prison in
Massachusetts he escaped from that jail
went back home to Liberia where he was
from and on Christmas Eve he invaded the
country but he only had about 150 adult
followers people in the capital didn't
even know they'd been invaded but over
the next couple of years he builds out
his force through child soldiers both
through abduction raids targeting
orphanages and through convincing
children to join some of the kids talked
about how they were promised they would
get a mercedes-benz when Charles Taylor
won the war
other kids talked about how they were
told they would get a home computer
obviously this is not a reason why you
join a war and Taylor didn't deliver on
it when he won the war within a couple
years Taylor is running what's called
Taylor land this Enclave in the jungle
where there illegally selling timber to
Western corporations and he's pulling in
three hundred million dollars a year a
couple years later Taylor wins the Civil
War and he becomes president of liberia
so through child soldiers this petty
criminal became a king and then other
people looked at that model and it
spread like a virus and we saw child
soldier groups didn't go from Liberia to
Sierra Leone to guinea de cote de bois
you could find former child soldier from
liberia fighting as far away as congo
it's more than a thousand miles away and
we're hopefully we can talk about what
can we do about this and what are some
of the implications on this but where I
like to end on it is this is obviously a
dark issue but we have to face up to it
this is war as it is not how we wish it
would be but there is a take away when
we look back at history there's all
sorts of practices that have fallen by
the wayside that we now can't even
believe happened just a few centuries
ago it was considered completely proper
to take your POWs the prisoners that you
captured they were your personal
property and to use them as slaves a
little more than a century ago it was
your obligation it was the white man's
burden to go out and invade countries to
lift them up into civilization hopefully
we'll look back at this period when the
rules of warfare broke down as another
one of these anomalies but it's only
going to happen if we match the will of
those who have chosen to do evil to
children with our own will to do good
thank you
thank you there's there's a couple
issues that hopefully Roger and Peter
can address you know for those of us
that have covered conflicts where you
have militias and places like the Congo
child warriors arm children are perhaps
some of the most frightening elements
and I think as i remember you address
this in your book peter and perhaps you
can speak to it too as well they
oftentimes are especially when they're
as young as 12 or 13 they don't have I
think a concept of what it is they're
doing in terms of the actual killing
that they're carrying out and when
you're stopped at a roadblock and you
run into child warriors you sense that
there is no line of demarcation and
perhaps you could talk a little bit
about that I mean for those of us that
have covered these conflicts running
into a roadblock filled with child
warriors is far more frightening than
running into a roadblock of adults one
of the things that I was surprised by
during the course of this was actually
the younger the child is often the more
frightening they are to their fellow
child soldiers and you would talk to
kids in the range of 14 to 15
in Liberia and Sierra Leone who were
scared of the younger boy units and they
called them sVU's small boy units and
those were kids in the rages of 8 to 12
and they were frightened of them because
they didn't know what they would do and
one of the young boys in that younger
unit talked about if they got mad at the
older kids they just start shooting at
them and there's two things that I think
are important here the first is we have
to remember that these are not just
little adults there's actually physical
and psychological differences between an
adult and a child and when this 18-year
point is really important one of the
things is the part of your brain that
controls both your death concept but
also your vision of risk is the
prefrontal part of your brain and it
doesn't reach its full development until
somewhere between the age of 18 to 20
and that's why for example little kids
will climb a tree that we would not even
look at or when you go to a ski slope
it's you know you'll see them going down
ski slopes we would be scared to do
that's how this plays out in warfare and
these kids don't have a death concept
and they don't see the consequences not
only to them of the gunfire but also
what it means when they've killed and
then there's an added thing that these
groups often do they hop the kids up on
drugs and for example in West Africa it
was a mix of heroin and gunpowder which
they thought would make it stronger and
these groups don't just do it because
they're evil I mean they are evil but
they do it they have a thought-out
process here and it's two things the
first is it's a further disconnection
and the kids will say you know it was
someone else it was like I was on a
different plane when the bullets weren't
coming at me and what I was doing that
was someone else and then the second
thing is it meant as a way to bind them
into that organization to make them
dependent on it and that's another thing
that we have to be able to figure out
how to fight
well my experience Chris with children
in warfare was limited because my
inquiry in children of war was to look
at the effects of warfare on civilian
children populations however and in most
cases there in contrast and maybe as a
kind of layer a different layer of
thought but one that cooperates with
what Peter was saying I was mostly aware
of their the rational child the sweet
child the child who had to become the
adult in a situation where adults were
very dangerous and were knocking one
another off there were however even when
I was pursuing the story of children of
war which was a story before it became a
book two situations one in Lebanon where
the Palestinian children were being
trained as soldiers and I'd also be
interested asked Peter when this sort of
began more recently because i was in
situations that may have changed over
these last 20 years or so but even then
the palestinian leaders the PLO leaders
were there was an admixture of both
pride and secrecy about that they were
not it was not something that they were
going to boast about and then the other
context which was the most horrific that
I encountered was the consequences
rather than the thing itself of paul
potts work camps in cambodia and these
were situations where children were in
effect I suppose soldiers in the
maddened idea of war that came out of
Paul Pott in the Khmer Rouge but the
what they did to one another at the to
be sure at the behest of the adults was
the kind of torment that you could not
possibly nor ought you to imagine that
people could come up with ways of
inflicting pain both psycho
psychological and physical one of the
things in Peters fine book is what do
you do afterwards and how are these
effects
and what effects do they have however I
do remember and also I found that same
sweetness in Sudan where I went for
Vanity Fair because i came across so we
came across a group of four hundred or
so lost boys and they were setting up
camp and I must tell you instead of
finding anything bellicose or even
approaching it I found what one can
honestly say would be the height of
civilization the first thing these boys
i went with sebastian Salgado the great
photographer of human suffering and the
first thing they were interested in with
salgado and me was did we have beds
we're we comfortable do we have food
this from kids who had been gone on a
biblical track Trek all the way through
from the north to the south of Sudan
barely surviving animals disease famine
and so forth but i did also go for the
new york times magazine with with
Salgado again to Rwanda and there I did
we did come across young certainly in
their early teens young soldiers who I'm
I have no doubt would have knocked us
off in a in a second and I don't know
quite how to convey it because it's the
first time I've thought about it as a
result of your question but it was an
interesting experience if you can think
of the normal predisposition of adults
towards children is kindness and welcome
and you want to take advantage of the
situation where there to be embraced and
then you see that same child you can
remember those tendencies in oneself you
know how it can how it can easily flop
when you're a child to the coldest look
as if I were not a person but a target
in somebody to take out of the way and
these are it is on that capacity that
ruinous capacity of children that the
adults in these situations in the
military suit situations play they make
them feel that um that's of work that's
a good way of life that a war is a
reasonable pursuit there's you know
there's an emotional numb
that comes with killing whether you're
an adult or a child but sort of having
watched it from the outside it seems
that sort of numbing effect is more
pronounced in children 1 also gets a
sense and perhaps this is something you
can address that in war zones these
child soldiers do not have a high
survival rate over the long term you
know one I remember in the iran-iraq war
for instance the Iranians would not only
use young Iranian children but they
would recruit Yemeni children and send
them running into the mine fields but
there was they were not only expendable
in the eyes of the commander's but I
think because of their emotional and
physical frailty it seemed that there
was a very high attrition rate among
child soldiers and I don't know whether
that's something you really it's
definitely something actually connects
back to what you were talking about then
the Iranian Iraqi war they told these
young boys they would wear keys around
their necks because the key would unlock
your way into heaven when you died and
if during the Lebanese of or it wasn't
until the Iranians started sending and
revolutionary guards to train that then
you saw the rise of children there and
what what this leads to and why it
spread is actually teaching pathways
where groups learn from each other and
they've seen the advantages of this
another example is on loll Sena is a
rebel group and Nepal that didn't start
using child soldiers till it started
jointly training with groups from Latin
America and South Asia and it's a
particular group that uses girl child
soldiers and it
claims that it does it to aid women's
liberation again these groups are taking
advantage of kids and this goes to what
you're talking about of the the and
indoctrination techniques when you talk
to the kids there's often very brutal
techniques that are used to turn them
into soldiers some groups have ones that
are modeled after armies the Tamil
Tigers and chill Anka have a four month
training program where the kids get up
at 5am and they train until ten at night
and at the end of it they're quite
indoctrinated and trained other groups
particularly those that abduct force the
child to kill someone in their home
village it's a kill-or-be-killed
situation and when you talk to them they
say that's the breaking point that's
when I became someone else that's when
my old life ended in some ways they put
it and they develop coping mechanisms on
they call themselves by different names
on the jungle names is what they
sometimes call it and the names range
from sort of laughable ones lieutenant
dirty water which was a kid who everyone
joked he didn't bathe ever any kind of
smelled to blood never drive which that
first quote was from which is meant he
was always out there fighting and it's
another way of coping it's a
disconnection it was this other person
that was doing the killing it wasn't me
it wasn't this my old identity and this
goes to what can we do if these children
get the support they need it they can be
turned back into children and we have to
realize that they're not just child
soldiers they're victims of the most
political form of child abuse but just
like any other victim of abuse it's
going to shape their identity for the
future it might scar them but it doesn't
mean that they're lost goods forever and
some of the child soldiers I met were
one was a student at a very prestigious
university in new england another was a
major in the US Marines who'd actually
fought in the Lebanese civil war as a
child soldier but they were
to there are there exceptions to rule
most of these kids don't get the support
they need and it's a question of
resourcing I think that one of the
issues that has to be looked at as well
as the breakdown of nation states in
continents like Africa and I think that
you know especially with the end of the
Cold War you know I who had been
covering insurgencies in Central America
that were disciplined of both militarily
I'm thinking of the Sandinistas of the
fmln but also ideologically all of that
evaporated and I'm wondering whether we
can really address the issue of child
soldiers when essentially we have
dysfunctional states with no central
authority with competing warlords who
essentially mount military operations
for personal profit and personal gain I
mean certainly covering the war in
Yugoslavia one very quickly realizes
that ethnic warfare is a business I'm in
all the Mercedes and Belgrade pointed to
that so I think that if we don't have
centralized Authority if nation states
are dysfunctional I'm wondering how we
can address that issue of child warfare
do you want to well I don't know this is
that this would be helpful but I'd like
to use you in fact to broaden it even
beyond the nation states to give to
remind us the context in which we're
dealing the whole idea of warfare of war
throws you into a mad set of other
consequences other forms of reasoning so
that the kind of torment or suasion that
is used for children becomes quite
reasonable and various minor tactics or
great strategies all seen within a
scheme of the of the intelligent and
and useful person but in fact this isn't
so and let me just read you a paragraph
from war as a force that gives us
meaning Chris Hedges book which gets to
this in a different way but does remind
us of the context many of those who defy
the collective psychosis of the nation
are solitary figures once the war's end
yet these acts of compassion were
usually the best antidote to the myths
peddled by the Nationalists going to
your nation state in question those who
teach those who reached across lines to
assist the enemy in quotes freed
themselves from nationalist abstractions
that dehumanized others they were
vaccinated against the cult of death
that dominates societies in wartime they
reduced their moral universe to caring
for another human being and in this they
were able to reject the messianic
pretensions that come with a nationalist
agenda by accepting that they could only
affect a few lives they also accepted
their small place in the universe this
daily lesson in humility protected them
they were saved not by what they could
accomplish but by faith such people are
however very rare and once you've
established as this elegant paragraph
gives us a context in which nothing
makes sense but the death of another
then anything goes children women
anything you can use for for victory
because victory is the only thing that
is of interest I think there's two
really important things here the first
is that the model of warfare has changed
and that
when you look at insurgencies it used to
be the maoist model that you would you
were a fish in the sea it would build up
your local support and that was the way
to success now it's the predatory model
it's sees what you can and the local
populace is just assets to target it's
about seizing diamond mines controlling
the drug trade you name it and we see
this repeated all over and so that
alters warfare and makes it harder to
end because you can't negotiate with
groups like this you also because a
child soldiers see groups that have no
viable ideology the Lord's Resistance
Army and Uganda is a group that's led by
a fellow who thinks he's the Christian
holy spirit and under his interpretation
of the Ten Commandments owning sex
slaves is allowed and riding bicycles is
a sin this guy is a nut job and he has
about 200 adult followers but over the
last decade he's abducted and built out
a force of 14,000 child soldiers and
he's fought a civil war so what this is
this is a David Koresh like figure who's
now operating in warfare and how do you
negotiate with a David Koresh like
figure you can't and yet he's carried
out this warfare and to go to the
question of what what do we do on the
prevention and deterrence side so far
the model has been one of trying to
shame the shameless reaching out to
these leaders insane didn't you know
that it's wrong to use children they
already know that and you can see very
subtle examples of it for example and um
Sri Lanka the Tamil Tigers there the
headstones for fallen child soldiers
don't have the date of their birth on it
because they know history is going to
judge them that way
so it's not a question of trying to
shame the shameless it's actually trying
to alter the dynamic create costs for
them not advantages and so that has to
include prosecuting them for war crimes
because this is the most easy to prove
war climb out there there's no question
of well I didn't know about this
massacre I didn't allow it if I had
known I would have stopped it you cannot
plead ignorance by the fact that sixty
percent of your force is made up of 12
year olds you can't claim you didn't
know but we also have to realize that
there are certain situations in
particular with these warlord groups
where we're not going to be able to
reach them they're going to be out there
in the jungle we will not be able to
seize them and so then we have to find
what is it that they want what is it
that they need and go after that is it
shutting down their weapons supply
shutting down the illegal trade and
light weapons which has been something
that the US has been on the wrong side
of that where we've been actually we've
made it harder to shut down the illegal
trade of light weapons or is it going
after the enablers the countries and
corporations that are trading with these
guys and pushing the profits into the
practice and you know a model maybe to
look at is the way we dealt with
apartheid where we knew we couldn't just
go after that government we also went
after the corporations those are some of
the things that we needed to think about
but at the end of the day we've got to
start making them March to our tune
rather than the other way around to what
extent our child soldiers and the
militias they serve the natural
consequence of the neglect on the part
of industrialized nations towards the
developing world
just I I think the question implies the
answer it if particularly for our
country the biggest country on the hill
if we choose to use this immense power
for what are to my mind you mad utopian
dreams of spreading liberty in the name
of warfare or warfare in the name of
Liberty whatever the cock-eyed idea is
it not only seems wrong in itself but as
an absolute avoidance of the question
that you asked the use of that power for
the powerless for the people who need
the help children being the weakest I
mean that remember which these two
fellows know particularly well the thing
about childhood is that it's helpless
the thing about Chavez that children do
what they're told that's how we in the
most benign circumstances teach them the
interesting and moral life that we hope
they will have but give the wrong
impetus the wrong way to teach it's
still the same helpless child who has to
go where he's told to go be pushed into
things the I'm going to spray a little
for the question i'll never forgive me
but but before i do are there children
present here good because i'm going to
tell you something that will lock this
in i'm told the story in a while one of
the i was talking about what adults will
do two children in order to create a
kind of a state of mind that you were so
horrific so nightmarish that you cannot
imagine the child scrambling out of
forever one child who came to the cow
Eden camp in Thailand the largest of the
refugee camps to which the Cambodian
children escaped when they could escape
was named Pope p EO v and she didn't say
anything for a year after
come to the scan wonderful psychologist
named Neil Boothby I must tell you that
if sometimes we are as doubtful of the
uses of Western psychology this was a
context in which it was heartening to
see that the idea of getting someone to
talk about even the most painful problem
can work anyway poet wrote drew the only
thing she did do was to draw a circle
that looked like a kind of wagon wheel
with a little circle in between and then
a little girl standing off to the side
and on a rope that seemed to extend from
the outer rim of the circle but it was a
confusing cipher to anybody looking at
this then finally after a year through
the gentle and useful prodding of Neil
Boothby she told what this all meant the
circle was used on a child who escaped
from the ball pot word can bar on
children who escaped it wasn't a circle
at all it wasn't a wheel it was a
portable guillotine that wasn't that had
been invented by you can imagine this
context of invention by the Khmer Rouge
this was placed over a child's head and
the lines of demarcation that looked
like spokes of a wheel were in fact the
demarcations of blades so that it worked
like a camera lens closed and open and
then the strings that you saw leading
from this were to close the lens and
therefore decapitate the child but it
wasn't the adults who worked this
terrible device the adults made the
children do it and so when Poe was not
speaking she was not speaking of an
event so horrific to her that it's
amazing that she ever spoke again and I
tell that story not to shock you or to
depress you but to give an idea of the
depths to which the the purposeful
adults in these contexts will sink if
they think it serves their purpose
Chris I think it's important to reframe
the question and reframe these issues of
aid the weather we are a stingy or a
generous nation or not and realize that
it's not just a test of our generosity
but it's about investing in the future
heading off future occurrences of US
soldiers fighting children or future
occurrences of terrorism and the like
and I'll give you two examples of this
um one is a Sierra Leone there was more
than is between estimates of fifteen to
twenty thousand child soldiers there and
the first UN peacekeeping operation that
went there they sent one child
psychologist one Sierra Leone was a
fundraising hub for al-qaeda where they
converted their cash into diamonds prior
to 911 another example is Afghanistan
there was more than 8,000 child soldiers
in Afghanistan that were used by the
Northern Alliance and the Taliban after
we toppled the Taliban it was two years
two years before we spent one penny on
rehabilitation and reintegration and
demobilization of those children so we
gave the Warlord's two more years to tap
into that 8,000 children and the only
reason we spent that money was it was
really about providing aid to the three
kids who we'd held at Guantanamo and
then returned back to Afghanistan and
there's you know an interesting story of
at Guantanamo we have camp x-ray which
is for the adults and little discussed
is camp iguana which is the one where
the juveniles are held and we've been
effect painted ourselves into a corner
where on one hand we treat these kids
really well in camp iguana it's a
converted house on the beach they play
volleyball they play they learn how to
play bocce they've learned mathematics
English they watch DVDs their favorite
film is actually cast away the Tom Hanks
movie because they kind of connect to it
one there's not a lot of dialogue and
the other part is they also see
themselves as someone who is plucked
away and dropped on a
our Island but at the end of the day the
military is frustrated by this because
they don't want to be in the business of
holding kids there forever and they
can't figure out how to get out of this
cycle and so it's not just a
humanitarian question but it also has a
military question to it I think we can
take some questions if anyone has any
please come to the microphone and please
keep the questions concise
hmm I'm curious about the the idea of
accountability for these these leaders
the International Criminal Court just
issued warrants against a bunch of the
leaders of the lra in Uganda and I'm
wondering what if if there's what if you
think there's a worry that that might
prolong the conflict you know you say
children are going to do what they're
told these leaders most likely are going
to tell them they're going to prosecute
you if you if you you know surrender so
what do you think is gonna happen is
that an effective strategy to try and
hold these guys accountable while the
wars are still going on thank you you
want to do that Peter I think it is as
long with a caveat the the first is we
have to make clear that these
indictments are not for the children
therefore the leaders who put them into
that and you have to have a public
affair strategy around of it to make
sure that that message is getting out
there the other part is the ice the
International Criminal Court is a great
start unfortunately the u.s. is sort of
done our utmost to undermine it and
that's a longer-term question I think
ultimately we will become apart but it's
not going to happen in the near term and
so then we go to the question well what
are the other things that we can do now
and we've actually started this process
of creating ad hoc tribunals the
tribunal for the Balkans Tribunal for
Rwanda but they've always been
geographically set there's no reason
there's nothing under the law that says
that they can't be issued based that you
could not have an ad hoc tribunal for
those that that targets those who use
child soldiers and one of the
interesting things is this would
actually be a very easy issue to get to
the Europe UN Security Council level
because the first is what nation is
going to try and defend that practice no
one on the Security Council is because
it's already a crime the second part is
the Security Council actually has
already issued a number of resolutions
that specifically identify leaders who
are using child soldiers so it's already
there at the international community
level who's doing it and the evidence is
there so it's something we can be novel
about it the other thing is you know
going after the enablers it's someone
who's aiding child abuse
and so when there are corporations or
other states that are profiting after
this we got to go after them as well and
you know this is one of the burdens of
the humanitarian community is that it's
focused all its efforts on outreach and
meeting with these leaders repeatedly
and nothing on enforcement and I guess
the last example that shows it which is
impertinent today is the Tamil Tigers in
Sri Lanka they signed a ceasefire more
than a couple years ago they've since
that violated the ceasefire by
recruiting mainly through abduction more
than 1,700 children including now
they're recruiting among the refugee
camps after the tsunami and yet the
international community continues to
meet with these guys they promise oh
we've stopped we catch them again they
promise oh we've stopped this time we
promise this time you can't keep meeting
with them you've got to start exacting
some costs
can you please come to the microphone
how many young people are at the camp
iguana and also our our troops prepared
in any fashion for coming up against
child soldiers when they do do they do
anything differently the numbers at camp
a gwan have ranged from three to six now
there's an interesting backstory to that
which is camp iguana is for under the
age of 16 we made up that age is our
determination it doesn't have either
backing in u.s. domestic law nor an
international law and so what we've done
is taken those that are between that
sixteen to eighteen point and put them
in the general populace which pretty
much ensures that they're going to be
pulled back into it when someone's in
prison they get pulled in by the leaders
so it's a small set that are there and
the decision to take that was one that
it was ad hoc and this goes to the
military response is because this issue
hasn't gotten the coverage the responses
have been ad hoc we haven't given the
intelligence support to our troops the
training the equipment all the kind of
backing that they need and there's two
really good examples of that the first
is when I was writing the book a couple
years ago we were about to go into
Liberia we had a US Marine Force right
off off the shore and I got an email
from one of the officers on board one of
the ships and he said we've seen on the
TV that there's some child soldiers
there but we've got nothing from
Washington about it neither how many
there are or what to do about it and I
wrote back and said actually sixty
percent of the force there an estimated
twenty thousand our children and it
would be important if twenty thousand
had blue skin let alone children with
all the dilemmas that it presents for
soldiers and so I sent him a draft of
the book but you know that's not the way
the system is supposed to work and then
we saw that also repeat itself now in
Iraq where on one of the things that
soldiers want to have
our non-lethal weapons not to replace
their rifles but to give them another
option on the battlefield something that
can incapacitate a foe but without
causing permanent harm the armchair
generals back in DC because they're not
big-ticket budget items haven't spent on
that and a particular incident during
the invasion was one where US Army
forces that were moving through Karbala
were being fired on by two Iraqi boys
that were between 10 and 12 and they
were shooting RPGs at them and the unit
which had not even been told that they
might be fired on by children stopped
pulled back talked amongst themselves
what to do so not the military optimal
solution first called out to the kids
said stop that didn't work then they
fired a warning shot that didn't work
and then they had to shoot to kill and
then that unit had severe problems in
its morale and psychological trauma
after the fact to go back to one of the
things they wish they had had was a
non-lethal weapon that could have
incapacitated those kids and allowed
them to advance what a save lives on our
side and the opposite side in the entire
US military there are 60 non-lethal
weapon sets we sent six to Iraq we're
not supporting the troops the way they
need it
I have two questions one is what is the
success rate of rehabilitating the child
soldiers and to what is the real story
on flying all these lost boys out of
Sudan on klm flights to Minnesota and
places like that is that a successful
way to rehabilitate people who've been
living in the skillet of the the earth
you know so you want it all I can I can
only speak to the rehabilitation
question in that in an anecdotal way but
journalism which I really don't do much
of anymore has very few rewards but
occasionally a story that you do has a
nice ending and when I did children of
war was a story cover story for time and
so time gets around the world and and
here and there were several people in
this country who reading about the kids
who were written about became foster
parents but one of them particularly at
the the there's no way you can see it
but right to little boy a Cambodian boy
named T Kim sang I myself am much
younger in this picture and the he has
he was reared in Massachusetts by a very
careful couple and he now is in his 30's
knees married and he stayed in touch and
he's come to see my wife and me just
written a little book about what he's
been doing now here's the boy who had to
bury his own parents and saw one of them
executed in front of his eyes and walked
60 miles on his own when he was eight
years old from cambodia to Thailand to
escape and I'm I must tell you the as
saddening as the original story was with
this boy it's just as heartening to see
the resilience of children too I don't
know whether these not I'm not skilled
enough in psychology to know how these
buried torments may affect them but I
imagine they're not different in kind
that may be different in scope from the
from the sadnesses of all children
everywhere who's including ourselves who
managed to put things in proportion so I
don't know Peter would speak to it much
more authoritative Lee I don't know how
the being a soldier would affect but I
know being a victim as a child seems to
have a creative situation where you
can't rebound I think it's important
remember that they're both soldiers and
victims at the same time and the heroes
of the book are the children who are now
out there trying to prevent other
children from falling into this and for
example in Sierra Leone there's a radio
station that targets children but it's
actually operated by children and so
there are the kids can recover but again
it's the big if are they getting the
support that they need are we investing
in the rehabilitation programs
demobilization etc to break the cycle
and when we don't we shouldn't be
surprised that these wars start up over
and over and over again and so again we
should look at these as opportunities to
head off warfare not just as nice things
that we're doing the question you asked
of the Lost Boys there's actually an
interesting backstory to where the lost
boys came from and the lost boys were
during the Sudanese Civil War the rebel
force there was numbers of refugee and
they set up a deal with the humanitarian
groups that they would have a camp for
boys next to the military camp
and the aid groups went along with that
and the reason was that the rebel groups
wanted that pool of reserves right
nearby that they could tap into and when
the war went badly for them things fell
apart and that group of boys then moved
off into the desert collectively
together and it's been I think it was a
good three years moving back and forth
and ultimately they were as you said air
live a good number were airlifted around
the globe here many came back to the US
and it's the same stories of many of
them are now leading happy healthy lives
they're enrolled in high schools etc but
that's that's a bandaid on top of the
practice it's it's not the way you deal
with it in a hole
you know if I could answer if I could
the question was what Pete the question
the question was why did we do this in
Sudan why did we focus on Sudan and not
elsewhere and you know if I could answer
why the press chooses to cover one war
more than the other you know I would
have a career in media studies and one
of the things chris is written about and
also in the book is this question of you
know focusing on tragedy in the Balkans
at the same time you know there was so
much tragedy in the Congo and it's
important in terms of coverage because
that is then the aid follows and when
you look at the per capita aid that was
given towards the Balkans it was about a
hundred times higher hundred times
higher per person than it was in the
Congo and it doesn't mean that it wasn't
needed in the Balkans it just means that
you know we focus on different issues
why did we decide Darfur was the
important one but you know the other
ones ongoing weren't I just want to
speak to the issue of trauma which who
raised as somebody who spent almost two
decades of their life around this kind
of organized institutional violence
around a lot of violent death you can
never walk away from that without
suffering from various degrees of
post-traumatic stress disorder and you
carry that with you for the rest of your
life it's I think to somehow think that
people can walk away from a situation
like the Sudan or the Congo as a child
warrior and not cope with very dark
demons for the rest of their lives is
naive the tragedy is that you know the
lost boys are a fraction of one percent
here we're talking about people who
never escape these kinds of situations
and after they're traumatized
re-traumatized the other problem which
you run into places like Gaza or Liberia
is that in a way because they have been
robbed of their childhood they have no
other way to live no other way to
function and when they try and step
outside of that role as a as a warrior
or as an armed combat in a conflict many
times they fall back into exactly the
same kind of poverty and marginalization
that drew them into the arm movement to
begin with and so there's a terrible
kind of recidivism where people keep
being thrown back into these movements
that that they're there can be alone in
this kind of militia warfare that then
rises up again and I do think that
poverty and the breakdown of central
authority and the fact that those of us
on the outside intervene in such paltry
ways makes this a problem that is as
Peter pointed out is growing and and one
that I think and I think you do get to
this point in your book as well is going
to come back and haunt us because we all
live in one community we all live in one
planet and what the figures you had the
are staggering in terms of what is how
many people are living on less than two
dollars a day that's about a couple
hundred million a couple hundred million
what's more than that even I think I
mean we there are terrible terrible
situations that I think propel people
into this kind of Hobbesian universe and
we have to address the conditions to
create the Hobbesian universe one thing
to add in terms of how it's going to
haunt us is the flip side of this which
is one of the interviews I did was a
British soldier who'd fought child
soldiers in Sierra Leone when he went
back home he had to be hospitalized for
severe depression had to go to a
hospital to deal with it and as our
forces engage with these kids we'll see
this come to pass in a couple years as
well and were not prepared for it right
now because
were in denial that it's even happening
let alone that this is something that
soldiers have to deal with it is a
difficult issue to extricate from the
from the context I keep coming back to
this because one wouldn't naturally ask
the question well if we could remove
children from wars than Wars it'd be
great the if if we dealt with this
particular problem then the situation
itself would be where it should be and I
just find the whole notion of addressing
that what is the larger problem in terms
of the specific useful kind humane and
maybe even practical at some point but
you're still dealing in a larger
situation that will always recur as you
were saying because the enticements are
the same and the species is the same
I will I will ask the three gentlemen on
the panel if they have any further
closing comments and then we'll wrap up
and they are available to answer
questions and sign books as soon as
we're done here thank you I think the
only comment I'd like to add is that in
situations like Iraq in situations like
the Congo in situations like Sierra
Leone murder which is always part of war
and and I distinguish between murder and
killing is killing being the shooting to
death of an armed opponent and murder
being the killing of an innocent that in
in insurgencies in warfare where there
are no lines of demarcation murder
usually becomes predominant and that the
consequence of that kind of murder of
innocence we have a hundred thousand
dead Iraqis is one that distorts in
flames and rages a society and
essentially creates a culture of death
you certainly see it in Gaza with the
constant almost deification of the
Shahid's of the martyrs and you have
this yearning on the part of children to
essentially not carry out a kind of
vengeance and empower themselves because
they live in in a universe so distorted
where they were they it's not just that
they have the diminished power of
childhood but they and everyone around
them are powerless it creates it has a
kind of spiral effect it has a kind of
snowball effect that I think we're
seeing in Iraq and somehow in those
kinds of a conflict in those kinds of
conflicts all of the components work to
essentially foster and create the growth
of these kinds of militia this kind of
killing and these can entice these kinds
of children into it and it and it
becomes a matter of addressing the
nature of
the conflicts themselves before you can
begin to address the problem of children
warriors as well I have nothing further
to say but I'm happy to give Peter the
last word childhood's the point in human
life where identities are formed and
where the notions of right and wrong are
formed and what's happening with this is
really the destruction of childhood
itself where you're taking children and
plunging them into an environment where
killing is not only sanctioned it's
rewarded and it's punished if it doesn't
happen and the consequence of this is
not just Wars or more tragic it means
that wars are easier to start they have
a higher cost to them in terms of
casualties level atrocities means
they're harder to end and they often
start up again and so it's something
that affects us it's not just an issue
that takes place somewhere else and it's
for these reasons that children have no
place in warfare except for the fact
that now they do and so it's up to us to
end that
thank you very much
you